Sun Salutation is a series of continuous  yoga poses to improve your strengthen  your flexibility bring your hands to  heart center and set an intention such  as I am love or I will be strong raise  your arms towards the ceiling and ground  down through your feet Mountain Pose is  a foundational pose enjoy your hips  bring your fingertips to the floor and  keep a slight bend in your knees this is  forward fold bring your fingertips to  your shins and flatten your back halfway  lift pose is a pose for alignment  make sure your wrists and elbows are in  line arms by your sides bring your knees  to the floor and then lower down this is  modified chaturanga pose for  strengthening bring your hips towards  the sky and press back this is downward  facing dog step your feet towards your  hands hang for a moment then come back  to Mountain Pose and bring your palms to  heart center  [Music]